well catherine sawye joins me now from
the ethiopian capital addis ababa
catherine
uh it does seem that the involvement of
amara forces in the conflict in tigray's
area seems to you might say complicate
a very difficult process to try and find
a way forward for peace if that's at all
possible
well at this point it's very difficult
to see how
peace is feasible both sides are holding
their ground the tigran
forces really saying that they will not
relent and the amhara officials and we
did speak to the vice president of
amhara region
um calling saying that they're deploying
more amhara special forces to this
frontline areas territories that are
disputed currently those territories
are marked in western and southern
tigray
but the amhara officials say that
historically those lands
belong to the amhara people the tigrans
uh
say uh accusing amhara forces of taking
advantage of this conflict that started
in november
uh to seize territories and saying that
those territories
grand territories are what they want to
take back so there's a lot of hardline
positions
um and people really uh saying that they
need peace and the vice president we
spoke to say
that they need there needs to be a
peaceful resolution uh because
right now it's a planting season people
are being evicted from their farms and
they need to be
in their farms but he also said that
there's no legitimate government
that would stand still and watch its
people being killed
or being evicted from their homes at the
same story
um coming from tigran leaders saying
that people are being
um killed and you know accusing amhara
forces of human rights abuses so right
now
very difficult to see um
a feasible peaceful solution catherine
soy in addis ababa thanks very much for
the update
well let's take a look a closer look in
fact at ethiopia's diverse ethnic groups
so the oromo
community is the largest making up 35 of
the population prime minister abhi ahmed
is the first
oromo leader now the amhara people are
the second largest and they
say that they're being increasingly
marginalized politically
although tigrayans make up five percent
of the population they're in charge of
the country for 27 years
the northern region of tigray remains in
a state of conflict as tigran forces
push
south against government forces and the
allies and over in the east of the
country
ethnic somalis make up the majority of
people living in the ogden region
it has a history of separatist rebellion
against the central
government samuel getachew is an
independent journalist based in ethiopia
joins me now
via skype from addis ababa good to have
you with us on the programme i mean this
new front between government forces and
tigrans
and now the amharic forces only really
does complicate a very volatile
situation on the ground
they've been having this kind of
um sometimes invisible conflicts for a
long long time
since the beginning of uh the tplf
coalition era
of 1992 and this is just becoming much
bigger than
it has ever been um you know i've been
we've been watching it from a distance
the administration
is mobilizing uh thousands of soldiers
to defend uh pieces of land uh towns
they've taken it from the
cry side so this is this seems to be
uh you know going moving forward
and impacting so many people do do um
the government and its security forces
have the numbers and the strength
to fight on so many fronts or struggle
on so many fronts
it should be a challenge but the prime
minister said he's going to mobilize up
to one
million young people to defend the
interest of the federal government
and there's a motivation to defend and
to embrace
what the prime minister has been talking
since november
this is a you know a nationalistic
conflict
for the sake of ethiopia and there are
many many people young people willing to
fight
and he seems to have the numbers to move
forward
obviously this last few months we focus
very much on tigray
but which of these groups really does
form the strongest threat
to prime minister abe's rule
well if you look at oromo the oromo side
he
there is you know a growing misgivings
about this prime minister there's also
the olf uh the oromo side that did not
participate in the
uh current election that just concluded
a few weeks ago
and the threat for him comes really
comes from moromia
but there's also misgivings all over the
country you know conflicts while we
focus on the third region
this kind of conflict is all over the
country and it's from
every single uh part of the country and
this is
really challenging uh the government in
an era where
it's really having no resources to uh
move forward with uh growing challenges
uh of unemployment
and uh you know investors that are
moving away so this challenge is going
to go uh onward for the new elected
prime minister
samuel goethe always good to get your
insight thanks for joining us from addis
ababa
thank you